I'm a quantum physicist and we quantum
physicists don't believe that the Big
Bang happened once that would violate
the Heisenberg uncertainty principle and
that means that there could be multiple
bangs happening all the time even as we
speak today universes are being created
and that fits the data the inflationary
universe is a quantum theory so there's
a certain finite probability that
universes are being created all the time
and for me this is actually rather
aesthetically pleasing because you know
I was raised as a presbyterian but my
parents were Buddhists and there's two
diametrically opposed ideas about the
universe in Buddhism there's only
nirvana
there's no beginning there's no end
there's only timelessness
but in Christianity there is the instant
when God said let there be light in
other words an instant of creation so
I've had these two mutually exclusive
ideas in my head and I now realize that
it's possible to Mel them into a single
theory either the universe had a
beginning or it didn't right
wrong you see our universe had a
beginning our universe had an instant
where somebody might have said let there
be light but their other bubble universe
is out there in a bubble bath of
universes and that means that these
universes are expanding into a dimension
beyond our three-dimensional
comprehension in other words is
hyperspace in other words 11 dimensional
hyperspace
so Nirvana would be this timeless 11
dimensional hyperspace where big bangs
are happening all the time so we can now
combine two mutually exclusive theories
of creation and Stephen Hawking for
example even in his last book even said
that this is an argument against the
existence of God he said there is no God
because there was not enough time for
God to create the universe because the
big bang happened in an instant of time
therefore there was no time available
for him to create the universe but he
see the multiverse idea means that there
was a time before time and there
multiple times each bubble has its own
time and so it means that there could
actually be a universe before the
beginning of our universe so if you
think of a bubble bath when two bubbles
collide or when two bubbles fission to
create a baby bubble that's called the
Big Bang so the Big Bang is nothing but
the collision of universes or the
budding of universes
you